[Música]
se vocês viveram no brasil acompanharam
o ano passado em especial nos meses de
agosto a outubro
vocês ouviram falar sobre renovação
política
acontece que essa se tornou uma palavra
chave e eu acho que é importante a gente
tentar resignificar que tipo de
renovação política que a gente quer que
tanto se tem se falado isso a gente
conseguiu alcançar algum tipo de
renovação política
com as eleições de 2018 bom meu nome é
malu molina eu sou cientista política
assessora política e política
eu me formei ano passado na escola de
sociologia e política de são paulo
eu trabalho hoje como assessora política
da deputada federal tabata amaral que
está no seu primeiro mandato que assim
como eu também tem 25 anos também é
cientista política e é uma das promessas
da renovação nesse ano e eu também só
política porque eu fui candidato ano
passado e hoje eu sou suplente de
deputado estadual pelo pdt de são paulo
então obviamente que eu tinha que falar
sobre política hoje fala de um tema que
é muito caro pra mim que é o tema da
renovação bom ano passado a gente não
viu ator fala tanto de renovação
política os números da crise política no
brasil não deixam ir pra outro caminho
então você tem a esmagadora maioria dos
brasileiros totalmente insatisfeita com
o cenário político então os brasileiros
não estão satisfeitos com os seus
governantes após o que aqui mesmo depois
da eleição tem muita gente que não está
satisfeita porque foi uma eleição
extremamente polarizada então os
brasileiros não acreditam que os
políticos defendem os interesses da
população os brasileiros não acham que a
democracia respeitada e não acho que o
problema é de um partido ou de outro mas
do sistema político inteiro
então nesse cenário a gente se pergunta
qual é o papel da renovação política é
óbvio que nuno durante o período
eleitoral os políticos não se vender
como novos que estamos falando de novas
propostas novas idéias
mas será que a gente conseguiu renovar a
política
o tema do momento do principal problema
do país era a corrupção
então óbvio que a gente vai ouvir um
monte de político falando que é contra a
corrupção inclusive os próprios acusados
e condenados
isso é um ponto importante para a gente
entender que tipo de renovação a gente
conseguiu alcançar ou não e os números
que a gente consegue ter aqui de 513
deputados federais eu acho que a gente
pode pegar o exemplo da câmara é 243
foram eleitos pela primeira vez na casa
isso simboliza uma altíssima taxa de
renovação a maior dos últimos 20 anos e
desses 243 115 estão começando o seu
primeiro mandato na política não tinha
nenhum cargo antes isso a gente pode
falar que houve sim renovação mas a
gente conseguiu resolveu a crise de
representatividade eu acho que não
apesar de a gente ter conseguido avançar
os números ainda são muito baixos quando
a gente fala de mulheres e da população
negra e parda do país que são a maioria
da população mas continuam sendo minoria
política porque isso é importante
na verdade é importante renovação
política renovação de políticos mas a
representação política é um problema de
saída que eu queria falar com um pouco
com vocês
é a gente consegue renovar mas a gente
não consegue resolver de cara o problema
da representação política até porque ela
própria é um problema e não uma solução
para a democracia a representação
política ao dizer que ela está
conectando o povo ao poder
ela na verdade está separando o poder do
povo sim democracia vêm de demos que o
povo e kratos que é poder poder do povo
a você criar um mecanismo de separação
você está imediatamente chegando poder
dessas pessoas
então a representação até quando ela
acontece da melhor maneira possível ela
tem um problema que é de impedir que as
pessoas comuns que os cidadãos tenham
uma
são política eficaz então é a gente tem
um problema de saída que é esse da
representação política e aí você soma
isso a todos os escândalos de corrupção
que aconteceram a pior crise econômica
da nossa história com a população cujo
desemprego gritante em especial entre os
jovens com aumento das desigualdades
sociais em uma cultura política marcada
pelo clientelismo pela troca de favores
pelo jeitinho pela compra de votos
isso pare passo com o avanço da
democratização da internet o que
significa que nós somos cidadãos do
século 21 que vivemos a sociedade em
rede que tem transformado não só os
processos produtivos mas a maneira e
como a gente tem contato com cultura e
com a política a gente não quer só mas
acompanha a gente quer que a nossa voz
seja ouvida
a gente quer que as nossas opiniões
estejam sendo executadas
então como conciliar o cidadão do século
21 com instituições políticas desenhadas
no século 19 e baseadas numa tecnologia
da informação do século 15
esse é um desafio e o cenário não podia
ser outro que crise de
representatividade crise institucional
criada de referências e o que é mais
perigoso na minha opinião que a rejeição
à democracia com todos os tipos de crise
acontecendo o aumento do número de
pessoas que rejeita a democracia não só
no brasil e na américa latina como em
outros países desenvolvidos têm
aumentado muito e aí que mora o perigo
e a gente tem que lembrar um pouco do
que o tio falava a democracia ela pode
até ser a pior forma de governo possível
mas com exceção de todas as outras que
já foram inventadas e testadas
ninguém pretende que a democracia seja
perfeita poxa se olha para a democracia
fala sem defeitos
isso não existe mas a gente não pode
aceitar que acho que a democracia aos
poucos vai morrendo então para os males
da democracia só tem uma solução que é
mais democracia
então por isso o questionamento de que
tipo de renovação política a gente
falando não basta só renovar os
políticos é preciso uma renovação que
fortaleça e atualize a democracia que a
gente tem hoje no século 21
e quando a gente fala de fortalecer e
atualizar a democracia tem um desafio
que é o maior de todos que é aquele que
eu coloquei da representação política
que é como a gente reconecta a sociedade
com a política que foi separada no
próprio sistema democrático
representativo como que a gente consegue
fomentar uma cultura política calcada na
participação e não na compra de votos no
jeitinho no desejo uma cultura política
que promova o empoderamento e à
emancipação cidadã e não o
assistencialismo isso perpassa por um
direito que é um direito novo criado no
século 21 que é o direito à imaginação
política
só que tem um problema que esse direito
esse direito é o direito de você
reinventar a democracia de você inovar o
jeito de fazer política de pensar fora
da caixa de sermos competitivos disse de
olhar político olhar a política hoje
fala porque não porque a gente não pode
mudar
só que tem um problema de saída também
no brasil os direitos são iguais
bom a resposta que alguns direitos até
são ea gente vive um conflito na verdade
que é nós temos igualdade de direitos na
teoria e na prática a gente tem a
desigualdade das condições de vida e
essa é a nossa maior contradição que
talvez seja o maior desafio para a
renovação política de fato então de um
lado você tem igualdade de direitos
bom no brasil se você faz parte dos 105
4 154 mil milionários que existem no
país hoje ou se você faz parte dos 24
milhões de brasileiros que sobrevivem
com menos de 249 dólares por ano
você tem os mesmos direitos políticos só
que dá pra dizer que existem as mesmas
oportunidades
não não é novidade para ninguém que o
brasil é um país extremamente desigual e
quando a gente fala de desigualdade no
brasil é desigual a gente não está
falando que o brasil é um país pobre
ele é um país rico ele é hoje a nona já
foi a sexta maior e com
comia do mundo mas nós também somos o
nono país mais desigual do mundo o que
significa que é um país extremamente
injusto
então como que a gente vai falar de
direito a imaginação de renovar a
política se aprecie existem diversos
brasis dentro do brasil
se as realidades são tão desiguais então
aí eu trago uma frase do ganhador do
prêmio nobel de economia pelo seu estudo
é sobre a pobreza nessa frase econômica
simples e fácil entender a igualdade
política ela é necessária para que a
democracia existe exista e funcione mas
ela sempre está sob ameaça da
desigualdade econômica é e quanto mais
extrema fora desigualdade econômica
maior ameaça à democracia e isso é
perigoso porque a rejeição à democracia
ao modelo desenhado é que a gente tem
hoje que foi desenhado no século 19
ela cresce junto com o avanço da
desigualdade social que como eu falei
apesar da desigualdade social ser
gritante no brasil que você vai ter uma
vida completamente diferente do lugar
que você nasceu se você é homem se você
é mulher
se você é negro se você é branco é você
também vai ter uma condição diferente de
relacionamento com a política é então
quando a gente fala do avanço da
desigualdade
com ela vem a rejeição à democracia o
que significa o aumento dos discursos
ultra-nacionalistas discursos xenófobos
racistas discursos de ódio e preconceito
é que são os cursos que acabam se
tornando autoritários é esse é um best
seller de como as democracias morrem
o nome é extremamente impactante e os
autores eles fizeram eles trouxeram
cinco indicadores de como morrem as
democracias de como os líderes políticos
vão se tornando autoritários e
contribuem para isso
ele é um livro que foi escrito olhando
para a realidade política e social dos
estados unidos mas que tem muito a ver
com a realidade do brasil
então o primeiro indicador é que os
políticos começam a rejeitar as regras
do jogo democrático outro por
comprometimento com ela quando eles
falam olha se eu não
essas eleições não vou respeitar o
resultado das urnas foi tudo falsificado
ou então quando os políticos começam a
negar a legitimidade dos seus oponentes
e ao invés de tratar eles como
adversários que devem ser combatidos no
campo da democracia das idéias
os tratam como inimigos que devem ser
combatidos no campo da guerra ou seja
eliminados ou então quando estou leram
ou tem coragem o comportamento violento
das pessoas e de grupos sociais e estão
sempre a prontidão para reduzir as
liberdades civis de oponentes o que
inclui a mídia quando a mídia faz a
cobertura dos fatos ou até quando a
mídia crítica pode sair de saque de
câncer não está certo e começa a usar de
meios até antiéticos de censura
então esse nome é muito impactante
especial pra mim
acho que para a minha geração para
geração milénio
por que nós não podemos deixar
democracia morrer
nós não podemos aceitar ganhar menos do
que os nossos pais é logo nós os
milênios como eu falei a minha geração
que é a geração mais preparada da
história a que cresceu junto com a
internet que tem acesso a todo tipo de
informação a qualquer momento em que ela
quiser
aí a geração que conseguiu ter o maior
número de jovens formados no ensino
superior
a geração que é empreendedora que
cresceu com os novos tipos de economia
economia da cultura do conhecimento e
economia criativa solidária
compartilhada essa geração que está
muito mais preocupada em ter
experiências motivadoras do que fazer
hora extra no trabalho é uma geração que
busca muito menos o consumismo muito
mais a aprender com a vida com
experiências bacanas
essa geração não pode aceitar que nos
digam que a solução para os problemas
que a gente tem hoje é reduzir a
democracia e não reduzir as
desigualdades
então a minha geração milénio eu tenho
total certeza de que a gente pode
renovar a política de fato dos pés à
cabeça a gente tem uma missão porque os
brasileiros eles perderam a fé na
política os números que eu mostrei
revelam isso as pessoas que ganharam ela
a eleição revelam isso porque são
pessoas anti sistema
são pessoas que puderam votar porque
pior do que tá não fica
e a gente não pode deixar isso acontecer
os brasileiros perderam a fé na política
mas não no futuro ea nossa geração tem a
missão de se renovar os políticos porque
é o poder não pode ficar concentrado
sempre nas mesmas mãos e eu acho que a
democratização da internet ajuda muito
isso e nós tivemos exemplos vitoriosos
de partidos diferentes desse ano que
conseguirão fazer isso
e pra que a gente quer renovar os
políticos para inovar o modo de fazer
política e reinventar a democracia para
que ela seja mais participativa para que
ela seja mais inclusiva e efetiva de
acordo com a vontade popular pública e
não com vontade de pequenos grupos
privados e com isso a gente consiga
aumentar as oportunidades e reduzir as
desigualdades que são os que geram todos
os problemas sociais e econômicos do
nosso país
então como que a gente faz tudo isso
bom aí só tem um único caminho pode ser
do micro ao makro pela web ativismo
participando de movimentos sociais
participando da reunião do condomínio da
reunião do conselho participativo do seu
bairro acompanhando o seu político
fiscalizando em quem você votou ou quem
você notou a oposição acompanhando o
governo ou até se filiando em algum
partido militando dentro de um partido
ou quem sabe por que não se candidatando
a gente sempre ouve que não dá que não
tem como mudar
a gente não tem que falar porque não dá
pra mudar porque se a gente for foi pago
por olhar todos os motivos negativos a
gente não vai pra frente mas tudo o que
a gente pode fazer é o que tem que
motivar
tudo que a gente já conseguiu fazer na
seleção tem muito candidato bacana de
tudo contrapartida que vocês forem
pesquisar
eu acho que ele tem que servir de
inspiração para que cada vez mais jovens
mais pessoas comprometidas com a
democracia ocupem esses espaços e isso
não tem outro caminho que não ocupá a
política
obrigada